I still have a dream.
It is a dream deeply rooted in the American dream.
I have a dream...
...that my four little children will one day live in a nation where they will not be judged...
...by the color of their skin but by the content of their character.
I have a dream today.
I have a dream that I will go to school.
I have a dream that I will provide the best life possible for my family.
I have a dream that people will open their hearts and minds to those who are different from them.
I have a dream that all people will be able to express their opinions...
...and share ideas freely.
I have a dream that we'll learn to appreciate and protect our environment,...
...enjoying what it offers us, while preserving it for future generations.
We have a dream that we will one day live in a peaceful and harmonious world,...
...where everyone will be given the opportunity to be happy, safe and healthy.
I have a dream that Dr. King's dream of equality will no longer be a dream...
...and that it will come true for everyone, everywhere.
When we allow freedom to ring, when we let it ring from every village and every hamlet,...
...from every state and every city,...
...we will be able to speed up that day when all of God's children, black men and white men,...
...Jews and Gentiles, Protestants and Catholics,...
...will be able to join hands and sing in the words of the old Negro spiritual:...
..."Free at last!"
"Free at last!"
"Thank God Almighty, we are free at last!"